-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning actor
you know from
"American Horror Story"
and "American Crime Story"
franchises.
She's currently
starring in "Appropriate,"
which is playing on Broadway now
at Second Stage's Hayes Theater.
Please welcome back to the show,
our very good friend
Sarah Paulson, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my dear friend.
-Thank you. How are you?
-I'm so happy to have you
in New York City doing a show.
-Thank you. Yeah.
-But also,
I'm very excited to hear that
you're staying
in my neighborhood.
We're like, basically neighbors.
-I am. Basically neighbors.
And I walk my dogs
400 times a day,
and I've never seen you.
-You haven't seen me once.
-So it just begs the question,
where is your dog urinating?
-Yeah.
-Because I know you have a dog.
-You know I have a dog.
You love my dog.
You made me love --
It's what's called
a reverse Samberg,
how much you love my dog.
-I really love your dog.
-You really love my dog.
My dog is a pad-trained.
I know.
-Disgusting.
-Yeah.
-I'm just kidding.
I mean, whatever you need to do.
-Yeah.
But also, you know my dog --
my dog doesn't want to be
outside in this weather.
-Yeah, your dog is like,
a little, skinny mini.
-My dog has to wear
a sweater outside.
Basically, the only time
she does is like,
June 15th to August 15th.
It's like, two months where
she's allowed to be outside.
I'm very impressed,
and we were talking
about it backstage,
and I know you obviously
had no choice
based on how much
you love your dogs.
-Yes.
-You brought all three of
them out from California.
-I did.
I have three rescue dogs,
and they are the absolute
loves of my life.
[ Applause ]
-Great.
-Thank you.
But they're California dogs.
So like, every time
I take them outside here,
it is quite an experience.
It takes me like, 30 minutes
to put their little sweater on,
and they just really
look at me like,
"Why are we doing this?"
It's hell for them.
-Do they travel well?
-I'd never flown
with them on an airplane before.
-Okay.
I actually had one
very great experience
with just my one dog, Louise,
who is the more emotional --
I would say troubled.
Let's say troubled.
-Okay, gotcha.
I'm her emotional support human.
And I took her
out of her little bag,
and I showed her, like,
had her look outside the window.
And it was very clear
to me the moment
she realized she was like,
30,000 feet off the ground,
She did this whole, like --
And I was like, that's right.
You're very smart because,
you know this is not normal.
We're not
supposed to be up here.
-By the way, you're a terrible
emotional support human.
-Yeah, I'm like, "Look at it!"
-"Look at it!
You think it's bad in that bag?
You're in the air!"
[ Both laugh ]
My wife knows how much
you love Frisbee.
And she, I think maybe saw you
and said,
"Sarah Paulson's
in the neighborhood.
Try to give her Frisbee."
-I don't know
what to say about you
wanting to give your dog away.
-I don't want to give it away.
My wife does.
-Wow.
-It's terrible.
The problem is, we have three
kids and the dog...
-You have three kids now?
-Yeah.
-I think
I only knew about the two.
-Yeah.
Now you understand why
we want to give the dog away?
-Yes, I do now.
Now it makes sense.
-Yeah.
-I will take the dog.
-Gotcha.
We're just going to find you.
We're gonna find you in the park
with your three dogs,
we're going to sneak
the leash into your hand,
and you won't even know when
you get home that you're like,
"Do I have four now?"
This is fantastic
to have you back on Broadway.
-Thank you.
Broadway audiences, lovely,
enthusiastic.
-Sure. Yes. But also...
-Okay, great.
-I'm sorry.
I have to just take the wheel.
The people in the audience
are very loud.
-Yeah.
-I think you think
as an audience member,
and maybe --
I mean, I don't think this,
but it seems like they do --
that there's like,
a glass partition
between the audience
and the stage.
-That you can't hear them.
-That I can't hear you.
-Yeah.
-I hear
every sound you're making.
I hear your sighing.
I hear your frustration.
There are phones
going off all the time.
And then there's the lady
who's like,
"Turn off your phone."
And I'm like, what?
You have just made a bad
situation exponentially worse
by shouting at full volume.
Also, there's the, like,
the cough,
the freedom of the cough,
which is like, once one person
finally lets out their cough
they've been stifling
for two hours,
then 16 people are like --
[ Coughing ]
All of a sudden in the
quietest moment of the play,
it's just like,
a cacophony of coughs.
It's hell on earth.
I just feel like I have to ask
for a little bit of awareness
of, we are up there,
doing the play for you,
whilst thinking about like,
what we might have for dinner
or when the show is over.
There's a lot going on
in the human brain
while you're doing the play.
It doesn't help
if I see the person
in the third row doing this.
I can see you. I see you.
I can see you,
I can hear you, I feel you.
Your energy is all part
of our experience,
and I just feel like
I need to make a --
This is my public service
announcement, yeah, yeah.
-It's great. It's coming across.
-Is it?
-I like the observation
about that person
who thinks they're a hero
when they yell,
"Turn off your phone."
-Yes.
-Because I will say this.
I don't think anybody's phone
goes off in a Broadway theater
on purpose,
you know what I mean?
-Yes, they're not like,
"Can't wait to do this
in Act Three." Bing.
-No.
-Someone's like,
"Turn off your phone!"
They're like,
"I'm expecting a call!"
No one yells that back.
-No, they don't, they don't.
But this has been a very --
The play is quite, um, raucous.
There are many things
that happen that cause
audience responses that are kind
of amazing for us as actors.
-In a good way?
-In a good way.
-And then other times,
it's like --
The character I'm playing is
a complicated woman,
and let's just say,
sometimes there are
audience reactions
that are unpleasant for me
because they applaud
when I'm told off and it's like,
"Oh, I see.
You agree with Rachel
in the play
that I may have some
sort of psychological trouble."
And then I have
this sort of thing to do
at the end of the play
that is difficult to do
when I feel I have enemies
in the audience.
-Interesting.
-Yes, so...
-I have read that you had
a unique inspiration
for your character,
this complicated person.
-I did, Meredith Marks
from "The Real Housewives
of Salt Lake City."
-Oh, good. Great.
[ Cheering ]
-It's that and "Chimp Empire,"
which was on Netflix.
I don't know if
anybody has watched that.
It's excellent. It's about
a bunch of chimpanzees.
So if you figure out somewhere
between "Chimp Empire"
and "Real Housewives
of Salt Lake City,"
I found my character right
in the middle of that somehow.
So I'm not playing
Meredith Marks,
but I was inspired
by some of her physicality
and some of her intensity.
-Gotcha.
-Right.
-Now no one can make fun of me
for watching the Housewives,
which I've been doing
since its inception, basically.
-From the beginning?
-From the beginning.
-Are you a genuine fan, like,
would you be genuinely excited
if you met one?
-Heather Gay came to
the Sunday matinee of our show
and didn't come backstage,
but I saw her Instagram stories
during my intermission.
I probably shouldn't tell people
that I'm looking at Instagram --
-You're telling the audience,
like, "I'm doing a show!"
Meanwhile, you're backstage...
-I'm like --
Like, dislike.
Oh, where is she?
Oh, she's in Paris. How fun.
No, I'm very --
I'm really focused.
But Heather Gay
was in the audience,
and then didn't come backstage,
because she felt too shy.
Meanwhile, during intermission,
I went to everybody, knocking on
everyone's dressing rooms,
being like, "Heather Gay is
here. Heather Gay is here."
And people were
completely flipped out,
and we were all excited
and figuring out
what we were going to do.
Lo and behold,
Steven Spielberg was also
in the audience that day,
and people were like,
"Great. Where's Heather Gay?"
And I told Heather
this on Instagram,
and I was like,
"You better come backstage."
And she was like,
"I'm just too shy."
I was like, "Too shy?
I've seen like,
almost all of your body parts
on national television.
Like, what are you
talking about?"
-It's too late for shy.
-It's too late for shy, babe.
-Here's another PSA to,
let's call them
celebrity guests
at a Broadway show.
-Yes.
-You should always go backstage.
-You got to go.
And Heather Gay
maybe doesn't feel that
she qualifies, but she does.
And to me, it was like,
we got all excited,
and she didn't come back, so...
-Shame on her.
-Shame on you, Heather Gay.
-I think she appreciates that
she made an error --
-I think she's
going to rectify it.
-Yeah.
-Right? Yeah.
-If there's one thing I know
about Real Housewives,
it's that they learn and change.
That's the one takeaway
of that show.
Everybody's always
self-improvement.
The arrow is pointing up
for everybody.
-You have a wonderful cast --
Corey Stoll --
-Corey Stoll, Elle Fanning.
-Elle Fanning, I just heard,
she was on Jimmy Fallon,
talking about you
making her break.
You do a fair amount of yelling.
-I do a fair amount of yelling
in this play.
It is true, and so vocally,
it's challenging.
And so what happens
sometimes on a matinee day,
when my voice is not
appropriately warmed up
and I don't have
all the things...
Truly, I went into
your bathroom here today,
and I just started going,
like, bbbbbt,
like, warming up my voice
to get ready to do the play --
Anyway.
-The public one,
not my personal bathroom.
-No, I went into your bathroom.
I just wanted to touch
all your stuff.
Anyway, my point is,
I do a lot of yelling
and a lot of, uh,
cracky voice things happen
on a Saturday matinee,
a Wednesday matinee.
One time I went on stage
and I said the line,
"Alright, River," is my line.
Elle plays plays
a character named River.
And instead it came out --
[ Distorted ] "Alright, River."
And Elle was just like...
She looked at me,
and I was like, "Oh, shoot."
And then she gave me
so much crap about it,
and we laughed
very much about it.
And then
that night's performance,
the Saturday evening
performance,
she has a line
where she says, "My mother."
And instead she said,
[ Distorted ] "My mother."
And I was like --
So these things
happen on stage sometimes.
The horrible part of it
is that you're supposed to act
like nothing happened,
whereas in life, I would
have been like,
[ Distorted ] "Your mother."
I would have done a whole thing.
But you have to act
like it's not happening,
which is so bizarre.
-It's also
so unfair to the playwright,
who had never understood --
-By the way,
the playwright was there
the first time Elle laughed,
because Elle did something
and I went like this to her,
and she started to laugh.
And we both broke up
in front of --
And I think our playwright
was really like,
"Please don't do that again.
People have paid
good, hard money
to come see a Broadway play."
And we're up there like --
We're so funny to one another,
Meanwhile, the audience is like,
"We don't know what you're
laughing about, first of all.
And second of all, that's not
the story of the play."
But maybe they sort of
feel excited a little bit,
like they're seeing a secret
thing that happened onstage.
Right?
I don't know what this is about.
-I know.
-I like to do that.
-This has been an interview
that's gone full circle
where you're like,
"The audience is bad."
-The audience, you're terrible!
I don't care about them!
-I'm like, Instagramming.
I don't know what's happening.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy to have you
on my street.
I am going to go
to the park with Frisbee.
I want her to meet your dogs.
-I think we've decided
your dog is now my dog.
-I think we have too,
which just mean the world to me.
-Don't say I never
did anything for you.
-Oh, I never would.
-Took your dog away from you.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-It's so great to see you.
You guys, Sarah Paulson.
She's the best.
"Appropriate" is
now playing on Broadway
at Second Stage's Hayes Theater.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Punkie Johnson.
That's your face.